avant d'accueillir mon deuxième invité
marylène iapichino m'a rejoint un
plateau bonsoir alors pour la rubrique
patrimoine également consommation vous
allez nous parler d'une spécialité
culinaire bien connue des français c'est
le fromage chaque français consomme plus
de 25 kilos de fromage par an marylène
alors tout à fait nous sommes le
deuxième pays le plus gourmand en
fromage derrière la grèce il faut dire
que c'est un savoir-faire bien français
et dans les yvelines
on n'est pas en reste connaissez-vous le
bleu de chèvre cendré et le sens jacques
grégory non pas du tout alors ils
viennent du sud des yvelines du village
de la boissière école la ferme de la
tremblay contient 150 vaches et 350
chèvres qui passe à la traite deux fois
par jour et dont le lait par directement
dans la fromagerie interne à la ferme au
total ce sont 40 mille fromages qui sont
produits par an d'une dizaine de
variétés différentes
parmi elles le saint-jacques fabriqué
ici depuis 50 ans et sa déclinaison à la
sauge mais aussi le fameux bleu de
chèvre cendré primé en 2018 au concours
national agricole pour l'anecdote
grégory je n'ai pas pu rentrer dans la
fromagerie le secret du bleu de chèvre
est bien gardé je vous laisse écouter
olivier veillée responsable commercial
de la ferme de la tramblais là c'est le
persillé le persil et de chèvre cendré
donc c'est une fromage qui fait un kilo
qui est qui et très doux
assez crémeux est assez facile d'accès
pour tous les amateurs de fromage même
ceux qui n'aiment pas ni le bleu ni la
chèvre parce que justement il est très
doux en bleu lors du repas approche ça
peut être alléchant ce fromage on peut
le retrouver ou heil vous fait envie
grégory on retrouve ce fromage dans les
commerces de proximité et chez les
professionnels car la ferme de la
tramblais travaille avec des grossistes
ils vont même de l'exportation aux états
unis en nouvelle zélande et en australie
mais pas besoin de traverser le globe
pour en goûter je me suis rendu dans la
beauté tout un fromage embrouiller la
fromagerie de ludovic biseau en fromage
et meilleur ouvrier de france et membre
de la ligue des fromages et
extraordinaire se sont tous passionnés
qui veulent révéler les pouvoirs
magiques du fromage
j'ai retrouvé notre fromage yvelinois
mais aussi toutes sortes de variétés et
même des fromages qui avait disparu
j'aime bien faire découvrir ce petit
fromage de bourgogne qui s'appelle le
fermier au chablis
fromage de lait de vache l'aveo chablis
qui est un fromage que j'ai fait
renaître que j'ai ouï j'ai relancé avec
un camarade qui est fromager en
bourgogne dans l'yonne et on c'est un
fromage que se consommer dans mon
enfance qui avait disparu et j'ai voulu
le voir renaître et donc maintenant il
est aimé sortir on l'a mis au point il
est sorti l'année dernière et j'aime
beaucoup le faire découvrir et il a
beaucoup de succès alors il m'a confié
que ce qu'ils vendaient le plus c'était
surtout le duo star camembert bri les
franciliens prennent les habitudes de
leurs voisins normands ainsi que le
comté 18 mois d'affinage unique trop
doux ni trop fort c'est à dire c'est à
dire marylène à vous écouter les
yvelines sont en fait une terre de
fromage alors savez vous qu'il existe
même un festival des fromages d'un
département
il a lieu à meulan en yvelines depuis
plus de vingt ans le deuxième week end
du mois d'octobre
plus de 300 variétés ils sont
représentés et il à dire plus de 30000
visiteurs après le sud-ouest l'année
dernière c'est la bretagne qui mettra à
l'honneur en 2019
une cinquantaine de fromages et et une
vingtaine de vignerons seront présents
puis si vous voulez connaître les
secrets de fabrication du fromage
la ferme pédagogique de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines propose des
ateliers de la mamelle à la gamelle les
dimanches matin à 10 heures alors ne
vous précipitez pas trop les chèvres ne
sont pas encore prêtes elles viennent
tout juste de mettre bas et il faut
attendre le sevrage de leurs petits les
ateliers devrait reprendre aux vacances
de pâques
merci marlène pour nous avoir donné faim
dans ce journal merci pour toutes ces
informations